As we go to our next game,
Disease Songs. Disease Songs.
Everybody's all worried about
the spread of the Zika virus.
Luckily, Jamaican
YouTube sensation and OB/GYN
Michael Abrahams is teaching
people in affected areas
with Wi-Fi
all about virus prevention
with this viral video!
♪ Zik V
inna de Caribbean territory ♪
♪ But we no want that virus
take set pon we ♪
♪ Bore hole inna de tin
dem yu dash way ♪
♪ And change the water
inna your vase every day. ♪
So just do all that (bleep)
and you're fine!
That is catchy,
the song and the disease.
So in the spirit of this,
comedians, I would like you
to name as many disease songs
as you can in 60 seconds.
Examples may include
"True Choleras"
and "My Neck, My Back,
My Pussy, and Malaria."
I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock. And begin.
-Claudia.
-"Tiny Cancer."
Yes, points. Gillian.
Anything by the Cure.
Points. Paul.
♪ Whoomp! There It AIDS
All right, points. Gillian.
"Die Like an Egyptian."
Points. Claudia.
"It's Raining Meningitis."
Mwah. Points.
Paul Rust.
-"Shingle Bells."
-Points.
Gillian.
♪ Simply Irresistible
Bowel Syndrome ♪
-Points.
-Thank you.
-Claudia.
-"Get Out of My Dreams
and Get
into This Containment Suit."
Yes, points. Very well done.
Paul.
Uh, "I Just Called
to Say I'm Positive."
(buzzer sounds)